let me welcome all of you to stoic on X
Milwaukee this is the first one that
we've had here in the Greater Milwaukee
area by doing this we joined the ranks
of some of the other cities that have
been doing this like Athens Toronto
Moscow New York City Melbourne Australia
there's there's a few others but you
notice they're all kind of bigger than
Milwaukee so this is kind of a big deal
to be doing this this here glad all of
you decided to come out on this very
wintry day you know it looks like
winters finally hit in Wisconsin so
maybe it's a good day to be inside
talking about stoicism and it's
applications to everyday life this is an
event that's being put on in part by the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship so those of
you who are from the area if you want to
find out more about that we meet monthly
and sometimes during the year when it's
good right Dan leads stoic walk and
talks weekly here in the Milwaukee area
we do quite a bit of this sort of
engagement and this is part of
international stoic Week so
international stoic Week started about
2012 it was originally called live like
a stoic week and now it's turned into
this this massive worldwide event that
thousands of people participate in there
are events all over the world including
before it the big stoic on that happened
in Athens just last Saturday and had
somewhere between 300 and 400
participants there are still account X's
all over the place and other other stoic
events including we have sort of a
partner organization here the New
Acropolis of Chicago they are having
some some stoic events this weekend as
well so that that's good to know so if
you if you want to know more ask them
about that as I mentioned this is being
underwritten by a very generous sponsor
who wishes to remain anonymous in part
because they they exemplify what we
could call stoic benevolence
the idea that you do things not to get
something out of it not to get some fame
or notoriety but just because it's a
good thing to do this is a person who
has helped not not just this event out
but other stoic related events around
the world in recent times so this is a
this is a big thing for us here in
Milwaukee we have a lineups of some some
great speakers who are going to be
talking about different aspects of
modern stoicism and and kind of a nice
range here so I'm going to introduce our
speakers I'm also going to talk about
you know what what is stoicism just in
case anybody's wondering you know what
they got themselves in for and then I'll
talk about a little bit of history and
then I'm going to turn it over to our
speakers so we have Kevin vhost here
from Springfield right Springfield
Illinois drove up quite a ways he is a
very prolific public speaker has written
a lot of things for stoicism today as a
matter of fact he'll have another piece
coming out in this series of Stoics for
all seasons in the coming weeks so you
might want to pay attention to that you
have about 20 books I think right and he
doesn't just do you could say you could
call it applied philosophy in the large
sense he's also what is your your the
degree to the exercise fitness I forget
exactly what it's what it is it's a
that's why I used to be a member of a
board that certified personal trainers
that's right yeah and you do you do
quite a bit of speaking on that sort of
stuff as well so probably the book that
that if any of you have read Kevin you'd
know him best from is the porch and the
cross which is doing some comparative
work between ancient stoicism and early
Christian thought because they actually
had a lot of influence on each other
dan Hays is our second speaker Dan is
you know another member of the stoic
fellowship I would say
he's now a co organizer write
effectively he's been leading the stoic
walking talks which are a brilliant idea
they read some passages mostly Marcus
Aurelius at this point but maybe you'll
read some other things down the line
okay and they get together for for an
hour and walk and and discuss the things
in one of our beautiful local parks here
in the Milwaukee area we've known each
other I think since the inception of the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship and Dan is in
that and then the tech sector has
applied a lot of the things he's a great
contributor to our group in discussions
when people come and they have you know
questions well what's actually going on
with this passage here dan is often our
go-to guy then we have Daniel Colette my
colleague from Marquette University
visiting assistant professor right does
work on stoicism and work on other
authors you can certainly ask him other
authors other movements you can ask him
about that afterwards and Dan is going
to be discussing things in terms of the
history of ideas but bringing some
things in that are they're useful for
for modern life as well and when we say
modern as philosophers you know we don't
mean right now all right
the modern period begins you know with
Descartes and Hobbes and some people
push it back further bacon Machiavelli
but it more or less ended a while back
so we're now in a different period that
we sometimes call contemporary or
postmodern or late modern or any of
these other sorts of things so when he's
when he's talking about modern stoicism
or stoicism in modern philosophy it's
not exactly the same thing as stoicism
right now but he will be also discussing
that we have I do also want to say
something about the lunch that we have
coming up and the reason why we've
partnered with the restaurant that we
did so some of you know the tandem here
in Milwaukee those of you who don't I
hope you'll have a very pleasant
association with that after you eat
their wonderful food
the tandem which which is doing all of
our catering is owned by by Caitlin
Collins who unfortunately right now is
is a bit under the weather she had an
injury a while back but her her
restaurant is very ably administered
because she can draw on an incredible
amount of goodwill in the community you
might say well why can she do that it's
because one of the things that she does
is takes young people from the Lindsey
Haight neighborhood here in Milwaukee
and teaches them culinary skills teaches
them how to work in a restaurant and
then sends them out into the Greater
Milwaukee area so I think part of what
she's doing again this notion of
benevolence as part of justice for the
Stoics she's in a certain way without
you know Tooting a stoical horn
exemplifying that so we wanted to
partner with them they also have
incredible food so that's another reason
Stone Creek the coffee that you're
drinking is another local company who we
very particularly like they do a great
job in their sourcing another
organization that is particularly
interested in issues of justice and
fairness so and their coffee is
incredible as well what else do I need
to talk about lightning round talks one
of the things that we'll be doing is
these short three to five minute light
lightning round talks you can think of
it as a stoic open mic that allows
anybody who wants well if you sign up of
course anybody who wants to to give a
talk about their experience with
stoicism or a particular idea it is
there is a cut-off of five minutes so
that we can stay on schedule if you can
do it in three minutes that's even
better
brevity you know here is important and
we don't have it long you know cane to
pull you off a stage like the old days
but I will call time when it when it's
time for that and the idea is to get in
as many people talking about their
experiences as possible because that's
always quite quite useful it's one of
the
great features of these these stoic
context events so I wanted to talk very
briefly about what is stoicism and a
little bit about the history of stoicism
and so why we're having this this here
today I think a lot of you know quite a
bit about stoicism so for many of you
this is just sort of review and you can
you know kind of doze off a few if you
wish to but but it may be useful for
some other so so what is stoicism it's
one of the great ancient schools of
philosophy that has its origin in Athens
with this guy Xena of Kidd iam very
brief story he's shipwrecked and he sees
his fortune literally ebbing away into
the Athenian Harbor because it was
carrying royal purple he goes into a
bookstore starts reading Xenophon
stories about Socrates the memorabilia
asked where can I find somebody like
this and the bookseller says well you're
in luck buddy because there's krottas
right there and go study with him karate
ace was a cynic philosopher he studies
with crotch ace for about ten years he
also studies with with two other
philosophers still Poe and pull them all
representing the Megerian and Platonic
Academy and then he forms the synthesis
and he starts teaching at a place called
the stowaway keel a that's why it's the
people of the stoah and it takes off
before too long he's actually got a king
asking him hey can you come up to
Macedon de to you know teach me about
this he says I can't do it myself I'll
send one of my students and it becomes
one of the major forces in you could
call it applied philosophy in the
ancient world it spreads far outside of
Athens spreads throughout the
greek-speaking world goes into the Latin
speaking world as the Romans start
taking everything over and there are
quite a few important thinkers who you
know take it very seriously you might
have heard of Marcus Tullius Cicero the
great Roman statesman and lawyer who's
known for that as well but also a
philosopher and he was not a stoic
himself but he thought there was a lot
of really great stuff in what the Stoics
had to contribute so he he writes about
them quite a bit
he also introduces his you know friend
and and you could say I guess colleague
and compatriot in the civil wars where
they both faced Caesar Marcus Cato who
was a stoic philosopher who embodied it
didn't write anything down but he lived
it out
the Stoics that we know are mostly what
we call the late Stoics many of you have
read Epictetus or Marcus Aurelius or
Seneca they're all you know in in that
late period unfortunately we've lost
much of stoic literature with the
scrolls that are that are starting to be
you know studied from Herculaneum we
might get some new stuff back in the
Canon that could be quite exciting
unfortunately looks like most of its
epicurean but you know what are you
gonna do you know maybe we can find a
few things now so what is stoicism some
of the key ideas behind it are living in
accordance with nature a fully developed
human nature dealing with our thoughts
and emotions in productive ways and
we're going to talk about that a bit I
think each of the speakers will probably
hit on that at one point or another
developing the cardinal virtues of
justice prudence temperance and courage
as centrally valuable in a human life
focusing on what is and what's not in
our control learning how to make that
distinction well and I would say
discerning our duties to other people
and getting ourselves to actually do
them that's I mean it's very easy to say
well I should do this it's very hard to
actually follow through as we all know I
think if you don't then then more power
to you but I know from experience how
difficult can it can be so they've got
this basic set of ideas now how did we
end up with modern stoicism and how do
we end up here at stoic on axe stoicism
you know it was very important in the
ancient world in Western Europe it
largely got absorbed into Christian
thought they had an incredible influence
on
the you know monastic movements you can
see this very clearly and the early
writers like say John Cassian Epictetus
survives in a sort of Christianized way
where they turn Socrates into Christ and
you know call the the philosopher the
monk and you know a lot of its
underground at the time and then in the
Renaissance in the early modern period
it takes off again people start finding
stoicism a valuable way of approaching
things in its own right and I think this
is part of what Daniel is gonna be
telling us a bit about so then it you
know it goes on for a while and it
becomes part of you could say the the
academic philosophy that we sometimes
some of us study in school in the 19th
century it doesn't have a really great
you could you know following you could
say this is where people start using
lowercase s stoicism to mean things like
just being a tough guy and not showing
emotion which is not actually what what
uppercase s stoicism is about and in the
20th century stoicism undergoes this
very interesting revival and I'm gonna
tell you about it very quickly if you
can if you want to know more about it
can ask me about it later but I want to
stick to time so part of it is academic
there are people like a long who start
you know writing about the Stoics
researching them
Ernst Becker no Lawrence Becker sorry
different Becker I'm thinking of
Lawrence Becker writes a new stoicism a
real head cracker of a book if any of
you have ploughed your way through it
but very important within the academic
community we started attracting a lot of
other important researchers like
Margaret graver with a wonderful book on
stoicism and emotion so you got that
going on over here
philosophers and psychologists start
taking stoicism seriously again and then
you also have you could call it the
psychotherapeutic approach to it a lot
of people don't know that the the
cognitive revolution in psychology that
gives us rational emotive behavior
therapy cognitive behavior therapy
other you know similar things are rooted
in stoicism Albert Ellis draws
extensively on epictetus on other things
as well but it plays a central role in
that so you've got those things going on
and then you've got people practicing it
so you've got somebody like Admiral
Stockdale who is you know shot down over
Vietnam and happened to have you know
memorized Epictetus is enchiridion and
finds that it gets him through the
harrowing experience of a Vietnamese
prison camp where they're trying to
break him over and over again just
brutalizing him it helped him survive
where many of his comrades didn't so
stoicism is is serving a purpose for a
lot of people and then the other sort of
key ingredient in this is the internet
because we live in an age where we have
all this connectivity think about it the
fact that you could sign up for this and
find out about this I think almost all
of you through the internet it made it
possible for a new modern stoic movement
to develop and and I got into you know
sort of on the late end I was invited to
become the editor of Stoicism today
after I started contributing some pieces
and the old editor was coming down and
so I joined the team of the modern
stoicism organization which is now a
non-profit based in England that puts on
stoic on that does you know supporting
the stoic on X's puts on stoic week
which I mentioned we're in the middle of
right now and then there's another
important organization that arose as
well the stoic fellowship the
International stoic fellowship all these
the smaller member stoas for the most
part our member stoas of this
organization and they kind of work
together that's all possible because all
these things came together now the I'll
close by saying this the reason why all
of this exists is not because people
were like a stoicism that's kind of a
cool hobby to play around with it
changes people's lives it helps them to
transform their thinking the ways that
they're responding in terms of their
emotions and it really helps a lot of
people
out so that is why we're doing this this
sort of event obviously you're not going
to come in here and if you've got some
you know issue that you're you know
we're going to do a thing on
relationships later on Andy and I we're
not going like solve any relationship
problems off the bat but stoicism
contains a lot of really great tools
that over time you can start applying so
with all of that I am simply going to
turn this over to our first speaker
you